this is no ordinary rocket engine
limited by the technology of their times
engineers and physicists have theorized
this propulsion method for centuries but
the constraints of time may have just
lifted with NASA's revolutionary test of
this rotating detonation engine in
January 2023 with the very latest
advances in Material Science and
computational fluid dynamics NASA has
managed to break through to test a 3D
printed rocket engine that could improve
fuel efficiencies of rockets by up to
five percent a five percent Improvement
in efficiency for a rocket is not a
marginal gain rocket weights are
dominated by Fuel the first stage Saturn
V had a dry mass of 137 000 kilograms
when fully loaded with propellant its
weight was 2.2 million kilograms the
first stage was 94 fuel a 5 percent
increase in fuel efficiency represents a
103 ton decrease in fuel that's not fair
off the total dry mass of a Falcon 9
rocket this does not just provide car
savings it represents a drastic change
in capabilities of rockets allowing
humans to launch larger payloads further
into the solar system this latest test
of the technology saw the engine run 18
times with a maximum firing duration of
113 seconds per run this was a test and
the engine is not ready to use but this
test represents the culmination of
Decades of research enabled by newly
developed metals and Manufacturing
techniques and the very latest advances
in computational fluid Dynamic modeling
let's delve into the science and
engineering behind rotating detonation
engines to see how they work
engines powered by detonations are not A
New Concept the Air Force research
laboratory developed this highly
modified root and long EZ powered by
four tubes in which the detonations
occurred traditional rocket engines work
by mixing Fuel and oxidizer using a
continuous igniter with the igniter
typically located at the top of the
combustion chamber a flame front needs
to travel through the fuel mixture to
complete combustion if the speed of this
flame front is below supersonic speed
the combustion is called deflagration if
the flame front travels through the
mixture at over Mach 1 then the process
is called detonation almost all
combustion engines work with
deflagrations but as their name implies
rotating detonation engines use a
supersonic flame front to produce thrust
and as a result can produce more thrust
for the same volume of fuel however this
is easier said than done the energy
needed to initiate a detonation is very
large and for these pulsed detonation
engines used on the Air Force's test
vehicle the detonations needed to happen
hundreds of times a second we can
initiate a normal deflagration
combustion flame front which travels
through the tube and with some
encouragement will transition to a
detonation but the causes of this are
not totally understood and not always
reliably repeatable we know that
detonations happen more often when the
fuel is turbulent so to create these
conditions pulsed detonation engines
often include a physical barrier one
method to achieve this is by placing a
spiral inside the tube pulse detonations
have a more obvious problem they don't
provide constant trust they pulse
rotating detonation engines are the
solution to both of these problems they
consist of a ring-shaped combustion
chamber the process starts by opening a
valve at one end of the tube and letting
a fuel mixture fill the tube the valve
closes and an ignition Source at the
closed section goes off and the
detonation begins a shock wave begins to
travel around the circumference of the
ring this increases the pressure and
temperature of the gas behind it almost
instantly this gas then expands and
leaves the tube at extremely high
velocity creating thrust this cycle then
repeats with the shock wave traveling in
a never-ending Circle this clever
Arrangement solves the major problems
with pulse detonation engines by having
to only set off the detonation once it
eliminates the unreliability of setting
off thousands of detonations a second
and its continual spiral around around
the combustion chamber results in
consistent thrust keep in mind that
these detonation fronts are going fast
operating at Mach 3 to 6 depending on
the fuel mixture this means the
Shockwave completes a full cycle in a
thousandth of a second with operating
ranges between 1 and 10 kilohertz this
is an incredibly difficult phenomenon to
harness detonations release energy very
quickly are hard to control and are
unstable by nature in fact for the last
century of Aerospace advancement
Engineers have been working very hard to
prevent detonations in their rocket
nozzles during the development of the F1
engine in the Apollo program the
engineers struggled to control what they
called thermodynamic instabilities these
were in fact detonations that were
destroying the engine on June 28 1962
these combustion instabilities caused an
engine to be completely destroyed during
testing this problem was plaguing the
engineers of the Saturn V and it is
arguably the greatest challenge they
faced in scaling this monstrous rocket
to reach the moon a list of 18 potential
sources for the instability was made
this was an incredibly complex and
dynamic problem one method to reduce
instabilities and to prevent pressure
waves from amplifying off the sidewalls
like a sound wave was to install baffles
that separated the combustion chamber
radially several iterations of baffles
were designed but with no computational
method available the engineers of the F1
engine turned to the next best practical
method they set off tiny bombs inside
the combustion chamber during operation
to quickly induce small combustion
instabilities the combustion chamber
bomb was attached to the injector plate
with the Detonator inside the combustion
Zone
alternator was enclosed in nylon that
would have blade Away In the Heat of
combustion over time allowing the engine
to reach full operation before
detonation resulting in a pressure wave
that traveled through the engine just as
a combustion instability would the
engineers could test the effectiveness
of this new baffle design by timing how
long it took for normal operation to
resume after the detonation these
baffles effectively acted as acoustic
dampeners like the foam wedges we place
in sound treated rooms for decades
Engineers have been working to prevent
uncontrollable Dynamic detonations but
engineers and scientists are stubborn
kinds of people when they hear
uncontrollable all they hear is not yet
controlled and rotating detonation
engines effectively use the exact
phenomenon that these baffles were
trying to prevent allowing a Shockwave
to travel tangentially around a
ring-shaped combustion chamber the
appeal of using detonations as a combo
question and propulsion mechanism is
precisely what makes them dangerous
their quick release of energy we can
visualize the amount of energy we can
extract by comparing the combustion
cycle of a hypothetical detonation
engine and a normal gas turbine engine
on a pressure volume charge this chart
simply plots the pressure and volume of
air as it travels through an engine in a
gas turbine the air enters the engine at
this pressure and volume a compressor
decreases the volume at a constant
pressure it then moves to a combustor
where heat is added at a constant
pressure then the gas passes through a
turbine as it expands until it reaches
its initial condition again the energy
we extracted can be found by finding the
area enclosed by these Curves in a
detonation cycle we skip the combustor
stage completely and instead the
detonation wave increases the pressure
of the gas almost instantly spiking it
much higher this creates a much larger
area inside the curves the theoretical
differences in thermodynamic
efficiencies using this analysis method
are immense using hydrogen as our gas a
gas turbine engine has a thermodynamic
efficiency of 36.9 percent while a
detonation engine has a thermodynamic
efficiency of 59.3 percent simply this
means more energy is extracted from the
same amount of fuel however an increase
in energy yield is of no use to us if we
can't control it or it simply destroys
our engine to harness this energy we
needed to develop new materials and
Manufacturing techniques this is where a
new material especially developed for
metallic 3D printing comes into play gr
cop 42 a NASA developed alloy made up of
niobium chromium and copper a
high-strength metal alloy specially
formulated to not only have a very high
melting point but a very high thermal
conductivity meaning it takes more
energy to melt it and it conducts the
energy away more efficiently to prevent
itself from melting and critically NASA
has more recently developed a method of
using it in metallic 3D printing meaning
we can create incredibly complex
geometries with this new age material
maintaining this reaction is incredibly
difficult the Shockwave by nature is
traveling incredibly fast and causes
rapid changes of temperature and
pressure take the injectors they have to
be designed to handle not only high flow
rates but also drastic changes in
pressure and temperature as the
Shockwave Travels by conditions change
from 0.01 megapascals of pressure at 3
800 Kelvin to 2 megapascals of pressure
and 3000 Kelvin that cycle happens one
thousand times per second at minimum our
copper-based alloy can help us dissipate
that energy but these inlets need to
switch from injecting gas to resisting
the pressure of the shock wave in
milliseconds to manufacture an inlet
capable of handling these conditions the
engineers needed 3D printing a typical
machined injector may look something
like this but the designers of the
rotating detonation engine need to
handle backflow and for this they can
turn to fluid diodes which would be
impossible to manufacture with
traditional cutting tools the shape of
this passage allows fuel to flow easily
in One Direction but when the flow
attempts to travel in the opposite
direction it impinges itself resisting
flow effectively it's a valve with no
moving Parts a perfect solution for this
application the use of metal 3D printing
doesn't stop at the inlet every part of
the rotating detonation engine requires
delicate shaping to harness the power of
detonation from the combustion chamber
design to ensure the shock wave remains
in rotation to the tiny cooling channels
running through the walls the rotating
detonation engine that NASA developed
used a 3D printed thrust chamber that
was actively cooled using deionized
water it also features an aerospike
nozzle aerospike nozzles are kind of
like inside out nozzles instead of the
traditional bell-shaped nozzle it
features a cone at the center of the
exhaust aerospike nozzles allow the
rocket to operate more efficiently at a
range of altitudes to understand why we
need to cover some of the basics of
nozzle design the Bell nozzle operates
optimally at a certain external
atmospheric pressure to work at its most
efficient we want the exhaust pressure
at the nozzle exit to equal the external
atmospheric pressure if the external
pressure is higher than the exhaust exit
pressure we are operating in the over
expanded condition flow separation from
the nozzle occurs and energy is lost if
the external pressure is lower than the
exhaust exit pressure we are operating
in the under expanded condition the gas
expands outwards outside of the nozzle
and energy is lost however if we match
the exit pressure and atmospheric
pressure neither happen an exhaust
velocity is maximized making our engine
more efficient we could fit Rockets with
variable geometry nozzles like fighter
jets but this would add a lot of waste
complexity and cost these nozzles are a
lot bigger than fighter jets and until
very recently were single use aerospikes
provide a lighter simpler alternative to
variable geometry exhausts here the
shape of the exhaust is dictated by the
external atmospheric pressure at higher
pressures at lower altitudes the exhaust
is compressed against the aerospike
which redirects the exhaust to point
straight down no flow separation can
occur as the pressure is pushing it
against the aerospike as pressure lowers
the gas begins to expand and the
aerospike automatically compensates to
external pressure changes the exact
science of these aerospike nozzles is a
lot more complicated than this and
deserve a video entirely dedicated to
them alone but the key thing to note is
that they are uniquely suited to
rotating detonation engines as the
aerospike engine with this cone design
requires a circular combustion chamber
which the rotating detonation engine
also requires however this is a more
important reason to optimize the design
of a bell nozzle we need a consistent
chamber pressure in order to optimize
our expansion ratio with the rotating
detonation engine the chamber pressure
is constantly changing along the
circumference of the combustion chamber
the aerospike's ability to adapt to
external atmospheric pressures also help
it adapt to internal chamber pressure
changes there is a lot more to do to
make rotating detonation engines viable
these prototypes while promising
struggle to run for long enough to
produce prolonged thrust in 2021 Japan
tested a rotating detonation engine in
space which operated for six seconds
producing 500 Newtons of thrust and
while this was a proof of concept it's a
long way from the millions of Newtons
traditional rocket engines can achieve
the mechanics of detonations are still
not fully understood this means that
maintaining a stable detonation front is
extremely difficult the system is
inherently chaotic Engineers are
fighting against entropy to control
these powerful turbulent flow regimes
with each revolution of the Shockwave
more chaos is introduced to the system a
single Vortex on Revolution 1 can cause
a ripple effect until the rotation
becomes completely unstable by rotation
20. NASA even shared that their tests
sometimes fluctuate from having two to
five corrote hating detonation waves in
the combustion chamber at once this NASA
test was a huge milestone for the
technology they demonstrated that their
copper-based 3D printed material could
survive for long enough in this
environment with their longest run
lasting nearly two minutes and they
managed to successfully initiate the
detonation front multiple times with 17
restarts over 600 seconds the biggest
challenge facing Engineers of rotating
detonation engines is creating flow
models to predict these instabilities
and developing methods to dampen and
control these combustion instabilities
just as the engineers of the Apollo
program did all the way back in the
1960s the next real engineering video is
ready right now it's about the M1 Abrams
we detail its unique turbine engine an
engine type typically used in aircraft
but used in this heavily armored vehicle
for two special reasons we dig into how
the armor of the M1 has evolved over the
past four decades and how it works it
will be available on YouTube in two
weeks but you can watch it right now
before anyone else on nebula as a thank
you to our show supporters here's a
rapid fire list of incredible features
you can enjoy for the low cost of just
2.50 a month ad free videos Early Access
before anyone on YouTube exclusive
behind the scenes of our documentaries
like these two uncut interviews from our
helion documentary exclusive classes and
Originals for me and all your favorite
creators I know they are your favorite
because it tells me what channels my
viewers watch in my analytics we got
mustard Wendover Productions practical
engineering the list goes on and here's
the incredible Thing by signing up with
my link you aren't just supporting me
you are supporting educational creators
across the board because we all own a
percentage of this platform we created
it to give us creative freedom and we've
achieved that nebula is the lifeblood of
our Channel a sponsors and AD revenues
have dropped lately nebula is what is
ensuring our incredible team of writers
animators and editors across real
engineering and real science including
myself can feel secure in uncertain
Financial Times and that's thanks to you
real engineering started with just me I
barely knew how to animate I had a dream
of recreating the magic I felt watching
Nature Documentaries on TV growing up
but for engineering over the past six
years I've continually reinvested
Revenue to hire the incredible people
that make this channel possible Mike
Dylan Stephanie Eli curtan Lorraine
Josie Graham this channel is not just me
it's a group of dedicated people that
you our viewers employ if you want to
see real engineering continue to evolve
and increase in production value this is
how you support that mission 2.50 a
month for the annual plan and you will
get all that incredible content to boost
[Music]